I'm not afraid you will be you will be
hey everybody hopefully you've had a
chance to see the movie or you're
getting ready to see it really soon this
is gonna address some of the biggest
questions after the movie because that
quote from Luke where he says this isn't
gonna go the way you think it's going to
go was never more true literally that is
the biggest takeaway from this movie is
that almost nobody predicted all the big
twists just because of the sheer size of
the Phantom yeah there were a lot of
correct guesses before it came out but
the movie itself is just like one double
take to another with all these big
twists so I will say definitely spoiler
warning if you haven't seen the movie
yet we'll be talking about very specific
plot points and what happens to a lot of
the characters if you're brand new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get
everything there's a whole bunch more
Star Wars that we have to talk about
this weekend and I'll keep doing the
IMAX ticket giveaway for a while so
don't worry about that so starting with
number 10 what is the implied future of
episode 9 in the fate of the galaxy like
where do they leave things at the end of
this movie and where do they have to
pick up when we get to the next one most
likely scenarios is that because of the
hyperspace tracking twist the resistance
will make it to the outer rim
they'll replenish some of their supplies
but there's this whole idea about the
spark of rebellion so the main takeaway
is is that their force alone even when
they replenish their supplies in the
outer rim won't be enough to fight the
first order they're gonna have to make
some key moves that will cause systems
in the galaxy to back them then they can
turn it into a real fight you now have
the promise of the new rebellion which
is also what that little kid with the
rebellion insignia was all about he
seemed really mysterious like he might
turn into a big character but that's
just meant to show you the spark of
rebellion in the galaxy like people
randomly all over the place or starting
to join the cause is his grassroots
thing that'll hopefully catch fire and
burn down the first-order like Poe talks
about during the trailers one of the
more devices of plot points in the film
number nine
why did Luke try to kill Ben when he was
just a kid so the logic here is that he
saw this rising darkness that he felt
like he couldn't come
in one of the big themes of the film is
the idea of bad parents that don't want
their children in various forms or
another like Luke Skywalker is kind of a
parent to kylo Ren in the situation he
doesn't want this darkness so he tries
to get rid of him that also thematically
ties in with what goes on with Rey's
parents which we'll talk about in a
second you could also subtitle it awful
parents so I think a lot of people will
disagree with the direction they took
those characters because they want to
believe that oh you know Leia Han they'd
be amazing parents but it turns out in
this saga they weren't so hot neither
was Luke Skywalker but obviously the
next big follow up to that number eight
who are raised parents and how is that
important to the story the revelation of
who they are like what does that mean
for the narrative so we learned that
they were actually nobodies that sold
her off for money they're literally like
a bunch of junkies that we're looking
for another fix they wanted some drinks
because of all the mind-reading twist
kylo Ren is able to pick it out of Ray's
mind
they died in a grave in the desert
somewhere and Rey has always known this
on a certain level but hasn't really
confronted it so kylo Ren forces her to
think about it again but again why is it
so significant to the story that her
parents being nobodies the idea gets
back to that kylo Ren twist parents that
don't want their children in number two
the second big reason the idea that
anybody in the galaxy can be special so
that I think also syncs up with the idea
of that little kid with the rebellion
Signia the whole idea the spark of
rebellion it needs to be everybody that
burns down the first order it can't just
be a group of really special people so
as a franchise from a narrative
standpoint previously what we've seen is
is that the characters are special
because they're related to each other in
some way like you passed the force down
through your bloodline Luke Skywalker in
the film talks about how he was so
amazed with kylo ren's mighty Skywalker
blood as he calls it so when they say
that Rey's parents were just a couple of
nobodies they're saying that anybody can
be special like Rey and be just as
powerful as kylo Ren who descends from
the line of Anakin Skywalker Luke
Skywalker has this really important
quote about how the force doesn't belong
to the Jedi Luke has come to the
realization that people over romanticize
the idea of the role
a ship the Jedi had with the force there
were just people who trained their
abilities but there are many many
different force sensitive people in the
galaxy who aren't Jedi the idea of the
Wills the Church of the force like you
have people that can wield the force but
are not Jedi it also gets into some Leia
twist during the movie - like she isn't
a Jedi but she does use the force so
that's why it's important for the story
that Rey's parents are nobodies I think
people were just disappointed because
they were like wait a minute
they were nobody special ah but you just
have to remember why that's important
for a narrative perspective and you know
if she's able to redeem kylo Ren at the
end of the franchise then maybe we'll
still have some Skywalker's to talk
about in another 10 years but we'll see
so number seven another big thing that
has people upset who is Snoke really the
film itself doesn't tell you any of that
you get a sense for some of the scope of
his power he has some new abilities like
linking kylo Ren and Rey telepathically
across the galaxy which is pretty cool
but the film doesn't tell you where he's
from specifically what his origin story
was and what's going to happen to him
next given the big twist at the end of
the film there are a lot of people that
theorized that he might be the first
Jedi because of some of the etchings at
the Jedi Temple where Luke Skywalker is
staying there's a symbol on the ground
that has a figure on it a very yin-yang
looking picture that looks a lot like
snoke's character but we know that he
comes from the Unknown Regions so it's
possible if that's true if he is one of
the first Jedi that he just left the
order and went out to the Unknown
Regions and lay in wait building his
power and his resources until he could
find the right time to snuff out the
Jedi Order because that's his whole
thing during the movie he's he wants to
eliminate the spark of the Jedi but I
think the whole idea is is that just
because he seems like he gets killed
doesn't mean that's the last we'll see
of him because if he's just as powerful
as Luke Skywalker that it's always
possible that he'll come back to kylo
Ren the same way that Luke is implied
will come back to kylo Ren but another
big hanging plot thread number six what
are they gonna do with the Leia
character in Episode nine given what's
happened in real life in the way they
end the film with her like her big final
scene or they're just going to assume
her final fate at the end of Episode
nine and will she also be able to become
a force ghost even though she didn't
train to do so like Luke
Skywalker Yoda obi-wan Kenobi and Anakin
Skywalker where she could be a voice in
kylo ren's head the way they say that he
still has Han Solo's heart it's more of
a metaphor but they could do it in a
more literal context with Leia because
she's force sensitive so getting into
number 5 how powerful was Luke Skywalker
before his final ascension so the whole
idea is is that he just been lying in
wait reading these Jedi texts they make
a lot of jokes about the books
themselves not really big page-turners
they also make the joke that the books
themselves aren't that necessary
she also carries a lot of the things
within her that are in these books so
what are the books good for are they
good for nothing
they're just highly sought-after
collectibles but if Luke wasn't training
this whole time and he's able to project
his for spirit across the galaxy
he has got to be crazy powerful but not
so powerful that it can save his life
but the whole idea being that you strike
me down I'll become more powerful than
ever there's still a lot of argument in
the fandom about what force ghosts are
able to do in how powerful you get the
Clone Wars touched on that a little bit
so rewatch those Yoda episodes if you
want to learn more about that but number
four what's the future of the Luke
Skywalker character this is also one of
the most divisive things about the film
like how could you do this to the Luke
Skywalker character well the whole idea
at the end of the film see you around
kid is that he will be back but he'll be
back as a force ghost just harassing
kylo Ren trying to bring him back to the
light side the way that Ben kept
reappearing to Luke while he was on
Dagobah like he would just show up have
a conversation with Luke then go away
so because Rey is probably going to
continue training as a Jedi Luke will be
able to reappear to her to give her
guidance when necessary but number three
why did he not leave auch two so this I
think was partly thematically because of
the way they synced up with some plot
points during Empire Strikes Back and
Return of the Jedi like Luke went to
confront Vader to try and bring him back
to the light side the same way that Rey
is determined to bring kylo Ren back to
the light side Yoda didn't go with Luke
he's one of the most powerful force
users in the galaxy but he stays in his
hut on Dagobah because it was important
for Luke to go through this trial on his
path to becoming a Jedi so I think
that's also one of the reasons
Luke stayed on auch - but to be fair he
did leave auch - just not in the way
people expected like his quote in the
trailer this isn't going to go the way
you think it's going to go so number two
what's going to happen to kylo Ren given
the state of his relationship with Ray
and how they ended things you are not
alone neither are you then they grab
each other's hands they touch each other
so it's almost like they have this
special connection and then it becomes a
literal connection because of what Snoke
does with his force powers that will
probably continue in episode 9 Rey will
still be determined to bring him back to
the light side but given the fact that
they already did The Return of the Jedi
twist where you killed the Emperor and
they didn't do the redemptive moment
it'll be interesting to see whether or
not they actually do make it to a kylo
Ren Redemption but then number one WTF
what's going to happen to the future of
the Jedi Order
Luke is supposed to be the last Jedi and
technically he is when he dies because
Ray hasn't become a Jedi and neither as
kylo Ren so what will have to happen is
is that Ray goes back to auch - to get
Luke Skywalker's lightsaber because she
doesn't have one right now and either
she uses that or she constructs a new
lightsaber and she starts to explore
what the force is and develops a new
version of the Jedi Order but I think
that's part of the idea is that she and
kylo Ren could eventually give birth to
a new Jedi Order with a different belief
system than what you saw before so you
see this franchise in general these Star
Wars films sloughing off a lot of the
old baggage that came with them
so that they can do new things in the
future so I think a lot of people are
upset about some of those twists but I
think that's what they're all in service
up isn't getting to the new stuff so
they're not always shackled to the old
characters for the rest of time so like
in a hundred years when we're still
getting Star Wars films we're not going
back to Luke Skywalker every single
movie but just let me know in the
comments what are your biggest questions
after the film and what did you think
about some of the big twists some people
really hate it some people really like
it
but I think it opens up some interesting
opportunities for the future of the saga
after Episode nine like ten eleven
twelve whatever that ends up being but
what'll happen is I'll do Easter eggs
and more videos across the weekend so
just leave all your requests in the
comments below there is a new round of
that IMAX take a giveaway all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber leave
us
our Wars related comment on the video
congratulations to the winner from my
last video
Austin flowers please private message me
so I can get your contact details while
you wait for everything click here for
my non-spoilery review and click here to
learn all about Disney buying box in
Marvel getting access to all the x-men
characters again they actually did the
thing so thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight